we start with like sending a couple
ounces over you know doing this through
USPS or UPS or all three USPS Post
Office yeah there's FedEx and there's
UPS UPS is the worst they're criminals
okay don't call me the criminal wow
there's still so much packages from me
bro yeah they know they just know yeah
and they've got scumbags working for
them and I guess they don't shake them
down when they leave the Sorting
warehouses wherever they go yeah because
we had several boxes with like 10 or 15
pounds in them yeah that would show up
weeks later to the address Gone Gone oh
there'd be no weed in it should still
deliver it they would still figure out a
way to deliver